welcome back as soon as our next guest
dropped her debut album in 2020 it was
clear she was going to make it and also
that I was going to be obsessed in the
wake of her breakthrough hit more Hearts
than mine which is amazing she was
nominated as the year's Best New Artist
by the Grammys Country Music Association
and Academy of Country Music Awards
everybody thought she was incredible
I've been honored to cover a few of her
songs on this show I'm obsessed with her
songwriting it's so beautiful voice is
beautiful but now she has another great
album out performing her
grammy-nominated song Wishful drinking
Along With Sam Hunt of her album good
person give it up for Ingrid Andrus
baby I'm just wishful drinking give my
heart something to sank it better make
it tonight
[Music]
in the dark
looking for what's left of a spark
throwing them back like I got nothing to
lose it's a slow burn just like you
everybody says give it time but I'm
feeling like I'm stuck on rewind
throwing them back like I got nothing to
lose it's a slow burn just like you when
I'm a couple and I get optimistic like
you and me are realistic maybe I just
wish
[Music]
around
me I'm Wishful turn again
[Music]
never a step I'm getting closer thinking
that we ain't really over I know it
ain't right but baby just for tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
still drinking
[Music]
Footprints through my memories
[Music]
[Music]
drinking
[Music]
I wish for drinking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good person you won't regret it and
we're also gonna be talking to her when
we get back her new album is called good
person and today it is what I'm liking
[Music]
super stoked about this y'all we have
Ingrid on the line right now what's up
Ingrid
hey
I have to say first of all well first of
all that's a really rad chandelier
behind you um secondly congrats on you
just got another Grammy nomination for
yourself
nice little holiday gift but I also have
to tell you this is something funny so
when you came out like when I first
started hearing your music I was like
have I how do I know this human I knew
your voice and I could not recall why
but we've met before right we have yes
okay you had a songwriting camp in
Nashville yeah and that was the first
time I met you and I was trying to write
a beautiful song for you that is what
your voice is I but I had heard I don't
know if it was on a dimmer or something
but I was like I know this voice and I
don't know how and I am obsessed with
your records I think you're so magical
and your songwriter your songwriting is
so on point it's so beautiful it's
perfect like country storytelling like
writing but you have like an edge of
like pop rock in YouTube that I love too
like anyway I have to ask what what was
it like you know you get your Grammy
nomination you get so excited like you
know what I'm saying like what was it
what were you thinking so uh I actually
had my manager with me and we were
watching it and I
freaked out uh literally I mean I was
just jumping around my house and then I
celebrated by drinking an entire bottle
of champagne at the house
well I have to I personally like said we
have to make time for this because there
is a song on your new album good person
and it's called blue and y'all this song
it's my favorite of the I love the album
but my son has these like Caribbean Blue
Eyes like they're just so blue and I
know it's a more romantic song obviously
but like if you listen the lyrics it
could swing either way and I I think of
my son every time I hear and I play all
the time in my house I love that song
it's so well written just just simply
beautiful I think you do that so well
it's so simple it's so effective and
it's meaningful and heartfelt and I'm
just so proud of you I'm so excited for
you I've I'm such a fan and like at some
point you got to get in here in person
and sing either with me or for us or
whatever because I love you anyway thank
you so much Ingrid I hope you have so
much fun on your tour
good luck at the Grammys I'm liking your
post right now
everybody everybody you have to get her
albums she's incredible I love her
um but all right that we've hit the time
in the show and we usually give our
guests a thousand dollars courtesy of
our season long partner pilot pin makers
of G2 the go to Penn of the Kelly
Clarkson show but I think Ingrid's doing
all right y'all so she doesn't need it
so but in the spirit of the holidays we
are giving it to someone in the audience
instead so look under your chairs and
there's a check taped under one of them
who's got the chair
[Music]
wait what what's your name where are you
from okay hi Kelly Clarkson hi I'm
Savannah hi Savannah nice to meet you
where are you from I'm from Seal Beach
California okay right on you're from
right here in California not too far not
too far I love it what do you what do
you think you're gonna use the money for
I'm gonna pay off my student loans not
pay them off but they're bigger than a
thousand dollars but it's gonna go
towards some student loans okay oh they
are definitely going to be bigger than a
thousand dollars yeah but take some of
it just take a tiny bit of it and do
something fun yeah yeah all right just
helping you out Savannah okay
um well congratulations on that all
right thank you to all our guests this
hour Margot Robbie Diego Calvin Mr
Freeman
changing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]